each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
sir pleasure to have an account chandran
speaking today so we shunted from UCLA
and he's a student vomits I I and
ruffler ski and he's gonna be speaking
about a new and interesting paradigm for
cryptography thanks very much honey okay
so just some references in case you have
interested disappears and in crypto this
year is also a full version that i will
give you the link to later its joint
work with vipul goyal Ryan Moriarty and
Rafi ostrosky okay so typically in
cryptography every party has some sort
of an identity so for example it could
be your public key given through some
public infrastructure it could be your
biometric that identifies you in the
network or for example in the case of
identity based encryption it could be
your email id so if someone knows your
public key then they can encrypt a
message infinity or if someone knows
your email address they can encrypt a
message to you such that only you can
decrypt the message so the question is
can we have any other different kinds of
identities what else can be used as an
identity so a question we asked over
here is how about where you are right in
other words on three dimensional
Euclidean coordinates can we use this in
order to cryptography mean the fact that
I am standing at this particular place
gives me some sort of an identity I'm
here at this particular point of time so
that gives me some identity so can we
use cryptography mean out of out of this
kind of notion first where might
something like this be useful let us
consider a situation where you have
military base in the united states that
wants to communicate with the military
base in iraq so in a traditional crypto
setting the military bases would share a
secret key exchange between themselves
and then they can exchange messages
back and forth and everything is good
right but then what happens you have say
an honest officer who is captured by the
terrorists and then he's tortured then
he finally revealed the secret key right
so ideally what would we like to have
maybe we trust physical security more
right so maybe we are able to guarantee
somehow through some physical means that
those who are inside a particular
geographical region are good so maybe we
can guarantee that geographically if
someone has entered the military base in
Iraq then he is a good guy right so we
want to be able to send a message to
anyone who is ja graphically present
inside this military base in iraq so
ideally we want to send a message
encrypted to the military base in iraq
and only someone who's at a particular
geographical position someone who
possesses maybe some XYZ coordinates can
decrypt the message and no one else can
decrypt this message
one can think of other applications as
well you can have position based
authentication so for example if you
want to receive a message from this
military base in iraq and you want to
have the guarantee that this message
actually physically originated from the
military base in iraq some other
examples could be position based access
control so for example if I want to
authorize someone to be able to use a
printer which is inside a room but then
if he goes a little far away then he can
he no longer has access to to print in
this in this location and you can think
of many more such such examples so the
problem informally is as follows say we
have a set of verifiers who are present
at various geographical positions in
space and we have a prove or whose
present at some geographical position be
to become clear why I use the terms
verifier and prove or shortly and the
goal is to exchange a key with the
prover if and only if the prover is in
fact at position p so verifiers want to
talk to this approval and if and only if
the prover is at this position p which
has some coordinates XYZ then a key must
be exchanged with with the proven
otherwise nothing should happen now
before we look at that task let's look
at a corresponding related task which is
called secure positioning which is bit
more basic again we have a set of Vera
files who wish to now simply verify the
position claim of a proven at position P
so there is a prove again at position P
and now we are not interested in a key
exchange but simply the prover says hey
I am at XYZ and the verifies want to
verify that in fact the prover is at XYZ
and he is not lying and the verifiers
can run an interactive protocol with the
prove it at p in order to verify this
this claim so this problem has actually
been studied in a bunch of works in
wireless security but there is an
inherent problem with all of them so we
will get to that in a bit so what is the
previous technique that has been used
for for secure positioning first the
assumption is that
all messages travel at the speed of
light radio waves achieve this GPS is
used this in that in their current
operation we actually do not require
that they travel at a speed of light but
we just require that we can transmit
messages as fast as an adversary can
that is all so if an adversary can
transmit something at some particular
speed then even we can we can do so at
that particular that is the only thing
we need over here but it's convenient to
just say speed of light so now we have a
verifier and approval and they can use a
time of response so how do they do this
so the verifier sends the random lawns
are to the prover and the prover
responds back with this random norms and
the verifier measures how long it takes
for this whole protocol to take place
right and then just based on distance
and the speed at which it travels if the
prover is responding back you get sort
of a an estimate of the distance what is
the advantage of the protocol the
advantage is that the prover cannot
claim to be closer to the verifier than
he actually is right so he can he can be
very close by and and claimed to be
extremely far away that's possible right
he can just simply delay his response
such that it's coming from far away but
if he is in fact far away he cannot
claim to be very close by so one can
think about generalizing this and in
fact the thought cup and who
boarded in 2005 and use triangulation so
basically you have three verifiers v1 v2
and v3 and say you have a proof of P so
now each of these verifiers send out
random nonsense r1 r2 and r3 to the
prover at p right and the prover has to
respond back with the random nonce to
each of the verifies right again the
three verifiers measure the time of
response and verify the position claim
and you can just show just by
triangulation that this is secure it is
a cure but it is rooms a single
adversity what is the problem suppose
the oviposition p and you did have
multiple colluding at colluding provers
right in fact there is an attack what is
the attack so you have three provers
over here p 1 p 2 1
p 3 such that p 1 is close to v 1 p 2 is
close to v 2 and so on right so now when
v1 sends out the response r 1 p 1 is
closer to v1 than peers so p1 can
respond back in time and that's the same
case with all the other adversary
provers as well so they can forge their
responses as if it's coming from a
single prove ER at position p so rest of
the talk outline is going to be as
follows i will first describe our model
basic model in a little bit more detail
we call it the vanilla model it's just
basically the model that i was talking
so far and bit more formalization then
we'll talk about the problem of secure
positioning i will first show that the
attack that i just described can be
generalized in a way and in fact secure
positioning is impossible in the vanilla
model even if you allow any sort of
computational assumptions so any crypto
assumptions that you may be willing to
make it's impossible in the Manila
module right so given that we have a
strong impossibility result question is
can we do position based cryptography in
any other model and it turns out that
the bounded retrieval model which was a
model it's been been been in use quite
quite quite a lot recently i'll talk
about in detail that gives rise to
positive information theoretic one
Deacon sending out wonder if I sitting
at a message to approver tester then
send it to three provers sure sure I are
impossibility result just rules out that
as well is that might be a viable way um
yeah are impossible to result yeah you
can make any any assumption like that
that that also it rusev it takes into
account that the the prover could get
information from multiple verifiers and
have to send it to multiple verifiers as
well and even then it's there is a there
is an explicit attack that adversaries
can carry out that might get around the
whole for each other sponsor sure but
there is a way that they can do it and
I'll just I'll just get to get to that
yeah and then after that we will get to
what we really started off with what we
want to do position based key exchange
so can you actually exchanged a key with
this particular prover at position P and
again we present positive information
theoretic results in the bart election
of mine so first an outline of the
vanilla model so you have multiple
verifiers thumbnail v1 v2 v3 in this
diagram you have a proof of P for now
let's just assume P lies inside the
convex hull there are ways we can can
avoid that from some cases will assume
that the verifier scan send messages at
at any point of time to the approval
with the speed of light next we will
assume that verifies can record the time
at which they send the messages the time
at which they receive the messages and
so on we will assume that verifies share
a secret channel between themselves that
they can use to communicate before the
protocol during the protocol after the
protocol and finally we will assume that
we have multiple coordinating
adversities and since we are showing a
lower bound we will even assume that
they are computationally bounded and
even if they are computationally bounded
our lower bond holes yeah
synchros fast yes yes yeah so first
theorem that we show is that there does
not exist any protocol to achieve secure
positioning in the Manila model and as a
direct corollary of this we get that
position based key exchange is also
impossible in the main in a model I mean
any any protocol for position based key
exchange is also it can be easily seen
to be a protocol for secure positioning
also so I'll just present a high-level
sketch of our low bond say we have
verify as v1 v2 v3 v4 and we have a
position P and now we have multiple
colluding provers p1 p2 p3 p4 and we're
going to now describe the product you're
going to describe the attack in the
following me we're going to say let
there be any any protocol that achieves
it for approver at position p and we
will show how these provers adverse it
approves p1 p2 p3 and p4 can simulate
exactly the same thing exactly as if
there were someone at position p
responding to to the verifiers so it's a
generalization of the attack that
represented earlier so basically p I can
NEP I can run an exact copy of the
prover that's what we're going to show
and P I is going to respond to VI so p3
will respond to v3 P 1 and respond to be
1 and so on but all the pis will
basically run exactly the same copy as
the as the probe will show that
basically what what happens is that PJ
can so any prove we're at position P
will be getting information from say v3
and v2 and say he has to respond back to
v1 right so there's a total time taken
for something like this is the time
taken for a message to travel from v3 to
P because P has to make use of that
information in the first place and then
it has to go to v1 right but then the
adversary so in other words the blue
path is the path taken if there were to
be an honest prove over here at position
P right but then an adversary always has
a shortcut like this
and you can basically show through some
triangle inequality is that this is
always possible right and no matter from
where it comes but comes from here also
the same thing can be done so it can be
shown that p I can simulate an exactly
the same car PSP maybe at a slightly
later instance of time but then since P
is closer to V I then position P he can
respond back in time and so the
implication of the lower bound is that
secure positioning and hence position
based cryptography is impossible
remaining a model and even with
computational assumptions note in the
lower bound we never made use of any any
sort of computational mean fifth
whatever the prover was doing the same
thing the adversary's can do as well and
there is no sort of it doesn't rely on
any computational sumption awesome so
the question is other alternate models
where we can do position based
cryptography and it turns out we can and
here are some of the constructions and
proofs the boundary retrieval model is
an extension of the bounded storage
model that was introduced by modder in
92 what is the model say it says that it
assumes that there exists a long string
X which is a sale nth n and it has some
hyman entropy and it's either generated
by some party or it just comes up in the
sky and the original bounded storage
module said that X just comes up in the
sky and assume that there is the string
out there in the sky that has some hyman
andhera p that every party can can see
furthermore it assumes that all parties
including honest parties have some
retrieval bound beta in for some 0 less
than beta less than one right so in
other words the adversaries can can look
at the entire X and store any arbitrary
function of this X but then this is the
amount that they can retrieve is bounded
and it cannot be it's only some constant
fraction of the total length of the
string and bunch of works have studied
this model in great
detail but I won't get into all of them
but we'll just talk about how this fits
into our setting so what do you mean by
the brm in the context of position based
cryptography so again we have v1 v2 and
v3 we have multiple colluding provers
and it's like the vanilla model except
now since we are going to present
information theoretic results we do not
even assume that the adversaries are
computationally bounded so they can they
can run an exponential time for example
adversary's so we assume that the
verifier scan can broadcast some huge X
which is some large string X that has
some hyman entropy and adversities and
provers honest prove us as well can
store only a small f of X as X passes by
so they have some retrieval bounds they
cannot look they cannot download the
whole X as it passes by and a
restriction of the brm and the bsm is
that adversaries cannot reflect X in
other words they cannot send ex back and
forth and this is just while it's bsm as
well as brm framework so to make things
a little bit more clear some assumptions
we make is that we assume first that
computation computation is instantaneous
modern gps's do perform some computation
while using this kind of speed of light
kind of assumption we can relax it but
then we will get a slight error in the
position maybe not we may not be able to
say that a person is at X Y Z but maybe
only only be able to say that he is
within some particular region if we
start allowing arrow we also assume that
X travels in its entirety and not not as
a stream again we can we can relax this
but then again we'll get a we get a
small error in in the region that we
secure positioning so the question is
how can one physically realize brm is it
possible we have some thoughts on it it
seems reasonable that an adversary can
only retrieve some small amount of
information as a string passes by we're
assuming this was a huge burst of
information that's coming by it seems
reasonable that he can look at it but
then he can he has time only to like
look at some parts of it and only
small small fraction of it another way
they could do it is the verifiers could
split X into into different parts and
broadcast it on separate frequencies and
maybe it's hard for an adversary to
listen in on all frequencies
simultaneously but then can listen only
into certain frequencies and gets only
part of the information ok so now going
to our constructions what are some of
the primitives that we need we require
these tools called locally computable
studer annum generators from the works
of salil whaddon what are they basically
prg takes as input a string X with hyman
entropy just like what i was saying this
large string X with hyman entropy and it
takes a very short seed k which is
uniformly which is chosen from uniformly
random distribution and the output of
the PR GPR g of x comma k is guaranteed
to be statistically close to uniform
even given the seed k and some a of x
for arbitrary boundary at length
function a
okay and the most important thing over
here for us is that it is locally
computable so what I mean by locally
computable in order to compute PR G of X
comma K one does not need to look at the
entire stream the locally computable prg
from solid words and basically use the
sample and extract paradigm so basically
it says that if i have the stream x then
all i need to do is look at few bits of
this X randomly selected from some bits
of it and then I can I can apply the
extractor and I will get something
that's statistically close to uniform so
it's good for us because because honest
parties also are not allowed to look at
the mean they cannot they cannot
download the whole thing they can just
look like a little bit of written and
compute some infraction okay so as a
warm-up latest first present secure
positioning in one dimensional space
it's an easy thing to do for now so we
have v1 and v2 who are to verify us on
this on this on a straight line right
and now we have a position P that's on
the straight line and we simply wish to
verify that approver is at position p so
how can they do this even and me to pre
share a short seed k which is a seat to
this p RG v1 is going to sample this x
which comes from this distribution which
this long string which has hyman entropy
and X and K are going to be broadcast
such that they reach this position P
exactly at the same time what is a
proven at position P do computes PR G of
X comma K and response to the v1 with PR
G of X comma K again v1 measures time of
response and accepts the response is
correct and if it were received at the
right time now just quickly the
correctness of the protocol is quite
easy to see so note that approval at P
can compute PR G of X comma K he gets
both X and K so he can compute PI of X
comma kv-1 can compute PR G of X comma K
when broadcasting x1 broadcasting xv1
already knows ki k
so he can compute PR G of X comma K and
therefore can verify the response
correctly and the response of the proof
of frumpy will be on time because x + KR
sent such that they arrive at p at the
same time so it's just a total round
trip time from from v1 that's it now why
is this a secure positioning protocol
I'll just give you some proof intuition
for this so note that there are two
kinds of adversaries over here broadly
you can look at them as two classes of
adversary's adversaries who are between
v1 and P call them p 1 and adversaries
were between P and V to call them p 2
now when these two streams travel travel
pass what to each of these adversaries
get to see p1 can store some a of X
right for some arbitrary function a
right p 2 can store k right and then the
stream still travelin and p1 gets to ck
afterwards p 2 gets to see x afterwards
so what can p 1 dou P 1 can respond to
v1 in time he can respond his clothes
are much closer to be one then p is so
he can respond in time but then he has
only a of x + k right he got to see x
first so he could compute some a of X
right then he got to ck he just got a of
x + k right so by the property of
pseudo-random generators this is
statistically close to uniform so he
cannot guess the response better than
just guessing at guessing at random so
p1 is ok what about p2 p2 can compute PR
G of X comma K because he gets to seek a
first right and then he gets to see X so
he can compute PR G of X comma K but
then he is farther away from b1 than
peers so just by the distance bounding
for him to respond back in time is going
to take longer than then someone over
here so he's not going to be able to
respond back in time ok so this does our
secure positioning protocol in one
dimensional space we can sort of
generalize this in three dimensional
space how do we do this for now I
I will just make an unreasonable
assumption and then we will show how to
get rid of it so again you have v1 v2 v3
v4 you have a proven position p now v1
is going to a pic k 1 which is a short
see to this p RG and pre share it with
all the other verifiers v2 is going to
sample x1 v3 is going to sample X to be
four is going to sample extra basically
each of them sample a particular X and
for now let us make the assumption that
VI can store all the excess so assume
for now that v3 can store the X 2 v2 can
store the x1 and v4 can store x3 will
show how to get rid of it in in a mint
so now they can all broadcast their
respective streams such that they reach
position P at the same time and the
prover does an iterative application of
the prg so he takes k 1 and x 1 PR G of
x1 comma K 1 to get que tu pyaar G of X
2 comma K 2 to get k 3 and p rj f x 3
comma k 3 to get k 4 and k4 is broadcast
to all four wave files thank you again
verify check response and time of
response now the security of this
protocol will follow from the security
of position based key exchange that i
will present bit later but for now let's
just look at the correctness of the
protocol right so this is what each of
the verifies began with and then they
require approval at position p to be
able to compute k for right but in order
to verify that the response k for the
verify as themselves need to be able to
compute k for right how did they compute
k for so actually turns out the
verifiers cannot compute care for if
they do not store the excise like why is
that the case so remember the the ki is
were were applied iteratively right and
in order to compute k for i needed k3 in
order to compute k3 and needed k 2 and
so on right so v3 might need k2 before
broadcasting x2 in order to compute k3
because if he broadcasts x2 then there
is no way for him to
pute k3 if he does not know k2 at that
particular point of time and nobody else
can as well right but it just might be
the case that v3 might have to broadcast
x2 before our same time as v2 broadcast
x1 so at this point even k2 is not even
fixed so no one knows the value of k2
but at that time v3 might have already
had to broadcast x2 right so it seems
that the verifiers might not be able to
compute k for themselves so how do we
get around this so we get around this as
follows we basically let v1 v2 v3 and v4
pick k1 k2 k3 k4 at random before the
product basically fix every key that
goes into each application of the prg
now clearly verifies no k for because
they picked it themselves but they must
help the prover computed so as before we
won broadcast k 1 v2 broadcasts x1 and
in addition broadcast prg of x1 comma k
one exclusive odd with k2 so in other
words what they are doing is fixing the
keys k1 k2 k3 k4 right making one of the
shares be from the iteration so when you
apply PR G of x1 comma K one you get one
of the shares right and the other share
is broadcast so sort of just a secret
sharing of the of the keys and the other
verifiers do a similar kind of thing and
verify as basically a secret share the
ki San broadcast one share and you can
show that coupled with the security of
the regular protocol and secret sharing
that this protocol is also secure
so protocol is basically v1 broadcast k
1 v2 broadcast X 1 and K 2 prime which
is a share v3 broadcast x2 + k 3 Prime
and so on and how does the prove or
compute it proved our computes PR G of
x1 comma K 1 that gives basically share
to the next key exclusive that with k2
prime gives the share that is to be used
gives k to itself right then computes PR
G of X 2 comma K 2 and goes forth in the
process so the bottom line secure
positioning is that we can do is a key
of positioning in three-dimensional in
the Boundary retrieval model and even if
there is a small variance in delivery
time or in measurement of the times at
which you getting the message that can
be tolerated but you will get a small
positioning error so question is what
else can we do in this model can the
whole power of this can be realized only
if we can actually get some sort of a
key exchange with with a proven at
position P so in fact we can do that let
us look at again information generate a
key exchange in one dimensional space so
as a reminder the secure positioning
protocol we had v1 and v2 along a
straight line and you had a position P
right there were two types of
adversaries p1 and p2 and we noted that
p1 could not compute the key right if if
you viewed the response as a key it was
already statistically close to uniform
so great has the property of key right
furthermore we noted that p1 could not
compute the key so seems like half way
we are done p 2 could compute the key
but could not respond in time that was
the there was a problem that we had so
this cannot be directly used for key
exchange because there exists an
adversary over here you can compute the
key but we seem to have already taken
care of half the half the problem right
so maybe we can repeat it in the other
direction and couple it in some way and
get key exchange so in fact that's what
we do so v1 pics k1 and secret shares it
with v2 mean sends it to v2 as well v1
also samples X 2 V 2 samples this long
string X 1 and they both send such that
they arrive at P at the same time
and you do PR G of x1 comma K 1 to get K
2 and then PR GF x 2 comma K 2 to get
Katie so again you have two types of
adversarial prove as p1 and p2 p1 could
store a of X 2 comma K 1 and you can
give them k 1 for free and p2 can store
a of x1 comma Q so it seems like no
adversary gets to learn k 2 before or at
the same time that he sees x2 that's the
only only way he can compute PR G of X 2
comma K 2 so in fact that that is true
and this is in fact a secure key
exchange protocol in one dimensional
space in order to get a key exchange
protocol in three dimensional space we
we generalize it the same way that we
did a generalization of the positioning
again for now assume the verifier scan
store the x's v1 will broadcast k 1 and
X for v2 will broadcast X 1 and X Phi 2
streams v3 broadcast x2 v4 broadcast x3
do a iterative application of the prg
and k 6 is the final key now some of the
subtleties that arise in the proof is
that there could be multiple colluding
provers everywhere in space when you
could have one guy over here or
computing a of X pocomoke a 1 then
sending a cross to this guy who computer
a of X 3 combines then it combines it in
some way since the cross 2 p-4 and so on
the just and it could be endless because
we have here we are looking at key
exchange we are looking at there is no
restriction on when he has to respond
back he could work on it for forever
later on and so on we want information
theoretic security so it seems like
there are some of these issues over here
that that creeper so the proof idea is
as follows it works in two parts we
first have a geometric pop geometric
argument we first need a lemma ruling
out any adversary simultaneously
receiving all messages of the verifier
so we know that the prover does receive
all messages from the verifier
simultaneously how do we know that there
does not exist some other point in space
where all messages of the verifier do
they're simultaneously this is in fact
characterizes regions within the convex
hull where position based key exchange
is possible for sample region where this
might might look at her if the endpoints
are the vera files in the red region
shows where all we can get position base
k expand we can show that the regionals
is very large and then we need to
combine the geometric arguments to
actually characterize information their
adversaries at different positions get
what information does each adversary
learn and what can he send across
someone else finally we need to put that
all together and that is where the
extractor arguments come we build on
techniques from recent work of intrusion
resilient random secret sharing of
jimbob's key and pizza and we show a
reduction of the security of our
protocol to slight generalization of TP
07 that allow multiple adversity is
working in parallel so just a reminder
about intrusion resilient random secret
sharing scheme I our RSS and shot
basically you have n parties s 1 s 2 s n
right and they have long streams x1 x2
x3 + xn k 1 is chosen at random and
given to s 1 and s one computes prg of
x1 comma k one gets k 2 sends it to s2
who computes prg of x 2 comma k to get
skate 3 sends it to s 3 and so on right
basically this attract iterative
application of the of the prg and SN
outputs the key k n plus 1 okay now what
can an adversary do over here it
basically this models something like a
virus that can get into these processors
learn a little bit of information and
and get out right so basically an
adversity can corrupt any sequence of
players so an adversary can go to s3
learn a little bit of information then
go to s phi learn a little bit of more
information get back to s3 learn some
more information and so on right
so a boundary adversary can corrupt a
sequence of players with repetition as
long as the sequence is valid what do I
mean by valid over here the valid
sequence sequence must not contain the
exact reconstruction sequence as a
subsequence so we hear the way to
reconstruct prg the weight reconstruct k
n plus 1 would be to do s 1 s 2 s 3 and
so on up to s and if you were able to
look at s 1 s 2 and so on and then go
all the way to SN in that order then you
can learn k n plus 1 simply by doing
whatever the honest parties would do
right so as long as the valid sequence
does not contain s 1 to s n as a
subsequence then they guarantee that k n
plus 1 is statistically close to uniform
right so over here in this example the
first sequence is invalid because it
contains 1 2 3 4 5 as a subsequence but
second sequence is valid because does
not contain one two three four five
subsequence so dimm burski and Pietr Zak
show that k n plus 1 is statistically
close to uniform as long as you probably
adversaries from from from corrupting
exactly where this reconstruction
sequence so at a high level reduction to
I our RSS would be as follows we can
model again s1 s2 s3 s4 s why having
different different excise we can give
all adversities k1 for free and then
basically for any adversary in our
scheme over here any adversary who
computes any sort of information right
we can construct a corresponding
adversary in their scheme that has valid
corruption sequence right so we can
translate anybody in our scheme any
adversary and ask him to an adversity in
their scheme that has some sort of valid
corruption sequence right so we will
call that adversity as a corresponding
adverse effect so an adversary that we
have an a scheme translates to a
corresponding adversary in their scheme
with some valid corruption sequence but
this was just one single adversary so we
need to we need to make sure that if you
have multiple adversity how do you
combine them in order
present their views right so we need we
need a theorem to show that you can
combine two adversaries that have valid
corruption sequences in order to get a
single adversary that has again a valid
corruption sequence and so on and we
need to show that this is possible for
any adversary in our setting and there
and there we need to make use of
geometric Dominic llamas so to conclude
some other results that we have shown in
the paper is to get position based key
exchange in the boundary drivel model
for the entire convex hull region not
just the red region that I was talking
about but for that we need to make use
of some computation assumptions as well
we also show how you can extend our
techniques to get a protocol for
position based public key infrastructure
so if I want to develop a public key
infrastructure just based on position
then we can do that if I want to do some
sort of position based multi-party
computation where my input should be
based on the position and that needs to
come with some trust guarantee that i
indeed am at this particular position we
can give my my input into the
multi-party computation some open
questions remain other other modules
where we can do position based key
exchange I mean we got the boundary
retrieval model computational assumption
doesn't help too much except for this
particular thing it doesn't help are
there any other models verb in joint
work with Serge fur whipple Goyal and
Rafi ostrovsky we have some initial
results in the quantum model where we
can we can show that even without making
any assumption on bounded storage or
anything like that just regular quantum
model we can get a position based
cryptography finally could there be any
other applications of position based
cryptography thanks a lot and the full
version of the papers available on on
eeprom
this to correct Rick's a revocation
revoke a physician well it sort of the
position is it's tied to the time so
sort of the verifiers broadcast
something and they know at that
particular time this is the key that
would have resulted in the protocol
right and if they want to do a protocol
again at if they want to send a message
to somebody else at that position at a
later instance of time they need to run
the whole thing again everything's
revoked automatically because key is
tied to the time youjizz and you show
your facility result in this Sigma if
they don't set up at all if you get some
very small setup yeah I'm waiting
anymore so any kind of so unless you
assume that you have tamper-proof
hardware that's it cannot be cloned then
any sort of setup also doesn't help we
we show that as well but we requires a
strong assumption that so if it's
possible for all parties who ever want
that position to be verified or anything
like that to meet with the verifiers
beforehand at some point of times and
the verifies give them some trusted
hardware that cannot be tampered with
then you can do position based key
exchange we didn't find that that
interesting because we want to we want
to we don't want we don't want everyone
to come to the verifies in the first
placement the idea is to use only
position as sort of an identity but any
other kind of setup assumption any kind
of keys anything that none of them none
of them work we can show that playing
listen to computers
you mean the pru bizarre moving or yes
they're all passengers God if you want
to verify their positions well if they
are in motion yeah I guess you can you
can do it by sort of a repeated
application of protocols so measure
their their position at some particular
point of time then measure the position
again and then you can make sure that
they're following some sort of I mean we
looked at we thought about this in terms
of satellites we can sort of you can
sort of make sure that they are
following their orbit by sort of
measuring their positions at different
points of of time that would be so what
it is slowly yeah
in fact actually there is some work that
talks about the following two cases so
our impossibility result directly does
not prevent the following two if
verifiers were moving or if verifiers
were hidden so if the adversaries did
not know the positions of the verifies
although an impulse this impossibility
result directly does not hold through we
have attacks on both those protocols
that are that exist and in fact we do
believe that most of our work does
extend into a general and possibly
result for those models as well so I
really don't know if any other model
where I mean where the impulse meters
that doesn't go through other than say
boundary trigger module and the quantum
model suits
maybe seven possible results
so if I want to hide my location and so
maybe I mean I've wrecked on my iPhone
like
some of the rights and
but i might not want it
so we're doing so more going to military
base seven ish
I'm so nervous emeriti tribe you later
by enemies
she's are the problems of my privacy and
that's it
where do I me
even though I'm I'm responding back to
all these verifier ok so maybe situation
so if you think of a better plan for
example its economy exactly how radar
works but I'm assuming that service and
say no bounces off the planes and you
submits it like that we're gonna change
you can be
okay this TV ping but then what can you
do in order to place an order is there
or maybe if you have multiple planes now
can set some little things figure out a
way so that they
well appointed exactly
if the verifiers can make sure that
there are there are these these
colluding provers do not exist then sort
of then you cannot be cannot guarantee
anything I mean you would require if if
I a verifier need to be confused as to
where where this guy is right then I
need to then to use what we have i need
to believe that there are adversarial or
by design there are provers also who
will be giving these responses right so
i do not know as is if this if any of
this can be used but yeah maybe some
something might might be over there of
interest